okay as many of you know we have a
discussion forum that exists on reddit
for the David Pakman show we have nearly
7,000 viewers and listeners
participating there you can find it at
david pakman.com slash read it that's
our EDD i.t I want to go through some
interesting posts and discussions from
the subreddit including is the alex
jones issue about free speech or
antitrust I find this very interesting
because I brought this up when we were
talking about the alex jones controversy
the free speech issue is not actually an
issue when it comes to the government's
limitation of free speech it's not a
First Amendment issue
we can talk colloquially about whether
YouTube is de facto or or in practice
censoring by saying we don't have to
take Alex Jones channel but the argument
for me that is a stronger one than a
free if you're going to make it a free
spirit issue you have to talk about the
antitrust issue because how do you make
this a free speech speech issue if you
can successfully argue and there's legal
precedent for this I think it's a 1966
Supreme Court case which says certain
entities if they get so big and contain
such market share that they become sort
of indistinguishable Beata
from an official government entity or
actor all of a sudden government that
they have to be or can be regulated as
if they were governmental institutions
now whether it would apply to speech if
your YouTube and you're determined to be
that big it would have to all be
legislated but the point is if you're
really arguing that the problem is
because of YouTube size it becomes a
free speech issue isn't it really an
issue about having a system where
companies can get this big in the first
place yeah that's a fair case to make
but certainly I think libertarians and
folks on the right in general wouldn't
be the ones to make it in most cases
like they're not the ones to argue
against you know or to argue for
antitrust laws no their but it's it
would help them in this case that's for
sure
yeah and I think that this is something
that we we really
should be talking more about because
it's part part of all this is that
Spotify iTunes etc the reason we need to
think about them differently it's not
just a small business saying listen we
don't have to do business with everybody
as long as we're not buying non
violating non-discrimination laws their
case is that these are so big that it's
different well maybe we should look at
how they got so big in the first place
and you're right Pat a lot of them don't
want to do that
also from the david pakman show
subreddit what people mean when they say
free market healthcare and this is a
great post that was put together by one
of our editors who lists all of the ways
in which we already don't have free
market healthcare right people like to
say the system we have is a free market
system where health insurance companies
can offer plans if those plans are good
enough at the price they are charging
they will get customers and otherwise
the company will naturally go out of
business or they will have to either
improve the coverage or reduce the price
the problem is as this poster points out
we subsidize and tweak the free market
status of health care all the time
everything from public education for
those who become doctors public funding
of colleges to create doctors in the
first place subsidizing the costs of new
hospitals for for-profit health care and
hospital companies it's a very long list
and of course it's a very good point
which is that we like to talk about or
some like to talk about this industry as
a free market that industry is a free
market and very often it ignores all the
ways in which it's not actually a free
market but we seem to be ok with those
in principle or at least we don't see
anybody arguing to change those and with
a lot of these provisions you know tax
deductions for medical research which
lets the government pay for all private
medical research that's a modification
to the free market it's not a totally
free market and to argue that what we
should have is a free market healthcare
system would require getting rid of all
of this stuff that we already have and
there's not much appetite that I see to
do that from the left or the right
also from the david pakman show
subreddit this is kind of funny well
we've been putting up on social media on
Instagram on Twitter producer max has
been finding nuggets of wisdom from
the show and converting them to text
form and posting them online as quotes
of mine and unfortunately that has now
been perverted or subjugated because
someone took one of those quote graphics
and put what I think is a quote from
Donald Trump the quote that's being
attributed to me is yeah that's her with
the gold I better use some tic-tacs just
in case I start kissing her you know I'm
automatically attracted to beautiful I
just start kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wait and
when you're a star they let you do it
you can do anything
grab them by the [ __ ] you can do
anything that is not something I ever
said on this program or anywhere this is
a quote from Donald Trump but it's now
being spread around the internet it's
something that I have said I've said and
I am here to tell you today it's just
not something I've ever said I think it
sounds pretty presidential I wouldn't
get too worried about it if I were you I
I could get mice if it weren't for the
fact that I wasn't born in the United
States I feel like this is a quote that
could get me elected president it's not
gonna hold you back you could still go
on to achieve great things it certainly
won't limit me I joined the discussion
it's not all fake quotes of me there's
actually really good discussions that
happen on the subreddit you can find it
at david pakman.com /re d di t